hey and welcome to this course where I'm
going to teach you how to build a chat
application using react Jas and the chat
kit API I'll teach you this through 17
interactive screen costs and by
interactive I mean that you as the
viewer at any given time can pause the
screencast jump into the code and change
it you can let's see how your trainers
effects the output so I'll encourage you
to do that whenever you're confused so
that you make sure that you understand
the relation between the code and what's
being displayed on the page and I'm also
going to give you five challenges
throughout the course where you'll for
example be asked to finish up my code in
order to reach a certain goal however if
you don't manage to solve the challenge
don't worry I'm gonna show you the
solution as well so by the end of this
course you'll be comfortable using
react.js you'll understand how to handle
data how to structure projects event
handlers hooking up with api's and a lot
more secondly you also get to know champ
kit which is a super nice API for
creating chat applications it's
basically an API which gives you the
power to build whatever kind of chat app
you want without having to set up all
the infrastructure and hassle that's
involved with real-time chat
applications so by the end of this
course you'll actually have built this
chat application here it's a chat app
with multiple rooms which you can switch
through this menu on the left hand side
here you can also create groups and
thanks to chat kit it's as fast as any
other chat application out there and
towards the end of the course when
you've understood how the entire
repository works you're going to get
your own copy of this chapter room
through cloning in the repository and
save it to your profile and as a bonus I
want you to have your own personalized
chat application not necessarily just
the same as this one so we're going to
go through how to use CSS variables and
CSS grid to personalize the application
through easily changing the theme of the
app and also to shuffle around on the
different components and both of these
things are super simple to do using CSS
variables and CSS grid and there are
also two hot new technologies of modern
browsers that needs to be in the tool
belt of a front-end developer in 2018
and once you've personalized your chat
app I'm also going to point you to
further resources where you can expand
upon and build more complex features
into the app finally Who am I my name is
Pierre I'm a front-end developer online
instructor and also one of the
cofounders of scrim BA which is the
interactive coding screencast tool we
were looking at right now but without
further ado let's get started on the
first lecture of the course
hey in this lecture we're going to have
a look at the component architecture of
our app because in react everything is
based around components and before you
start coding your app you should break
the UI into components and it's a good
idea to actually do it visually like
I've done here using paint or a preview
or something like that to just draw
colored rectangles around your
components and the way you break your UI
into this is by starting at the top so
here
the parent component the common ancestor
for all other components is the one in
red hair that's normally called app or
main or something like that and it
basically contains our entire
application and then you ask yourself
which direct children does this
component have in our case it makes
sense to have four direct children
there's the list of rooms on the left
hand side here there's the chat area
itself
there's the form where you enter chat
messages and there's also the form where
you create new rooms so the app
component has four direct children the
green blue brown noir inchworm and then
you want to ask yourself again which
children does these components have and
this is just a form doesn't really have
any children same with this one whoever
the message list component the blue one
has a list of messages inside of it and
it's totally reasonable to turn them
into their own components so each of the
messages is a component itself and you
can actually also make the case that
this room list component should have
children as well because it has a list
of rooms here and you can even extract
this title here in a component it's
basically not written in stone and the
reason I've turned each of the messages
into components though not turned each
of these into components is basically
just to show you that it's up to you and
both things work so in general the more
complex your app becomes the more you
should split it up and a good rule of
thumb is the principle of single
responsibility you want through a
component to do one thing in one thing
only
so if you have huge components which
does a lot of things you should consider
breaking them up into multiple
components
so in the next lecture we'll look at how
these components turn into actual code
as we walk through the repository so
I'll see you there
heyyyyyy in this lecture I'm going to
have a look at the codebase architecture
so that you can build a mental model of
how this repository works before we
start coding we have the fully
functional app here right now so don't
worry if a lot of this looks scary to
you because at the end of the course it
won't
let's start like we did when we looked
at the components on a conceptual level
which was at the root level meaning the
red rectangle here the component which
is the ancestor of all the other
components and that is the AB component
as you can see lies in the root
directory app dot Jas and this is also
our biggest component this is where all
the magic happens in these various
methods here which will later on go
through step by step for now though I
wanna have a look at the render method
because here you can see that this
component renders out four other
components and they just happen to be
the components which were direct
children of the red one so the green
blue orange and brown which was the room
list message list new room form and send
method form the reason we have access to
these here is because we have imported
them up here as you can see they have
been imported from a components folder
that is one you can see right here if we
open it up you'll see five components
here's the message component for example
that is the one which is not a direct
child of the app component but a direct
child of the message list component the
blue one here so let's have a look at
the message list go down to the render
method and it is indeed returning the
message component meaning that the
message component is a child of the
message list component so hopefully now
you're starting to build an
understanding of how this architecture
here translates into react code we can
also have a look at the new room form
and the room list and the send message
form and as you might notice all these
components are much smaller than the app
component and that is very conscious
because we want the app component to be
a so-called smart component meaning it
handles all the logic takes care of
talking with the chat kit API as you can
see we've imported the chat kit sdk up
here and it also takes care of handling
all the data that's done in the state
here which you'll learn a lot about in a
few lectures so this is the brains of
our application where's the child
components like this message here is in
contrast actually pretty stupid they
only take whatever data they get from
their parent and render it out some of
them also have some event handlers for
handling input from the users for
example the send message form this one
down here of course needs to accept user
input however it doesn't do any logic of
the data it just takes the data and
sends it off and of course doesn't take
care of talking with the API nope
all that is done in the app component
and this separation is a best practice
as you want as many of your components
to be as stupid as possible while
gathering the brains at one place higher
up in the hierarchy as it's much harder
to maintain an app if the logic is
spread across tons of components so as
much as you can try to have one or a few
smart components and the rest of the
components as stupid as possible so
let's have a look at the other files
let's start with the index.html for
example it is ridiculously simple it has
a link to the CSS it also has a div with
an ID of route more on that in a minute
plus it's also linking to the bundle of
all of our JavaScript which is index dot
package a s and this pack here is
because scrim BA is using webpack under
the hood so it needs to refer to index
dot package is instead of indexed at a s
which is the one you can see here and
this is where we're connecting our react
app with the index.html file because as
you can see we're importing the app fjs
tricity route component
we're saying react DOM dot render this
app in the element with the ID of route
for taking our entire application which
exists in app as that's the common
ancestor for all of our components and
shoving it into the Dom which is exactly
here then we have the Styles and style
of CSS and we're not going to go through
the basic CSS in this course I was I'm
assuming that you know basic CSS whoever
we're going to look at both CSS
variables and CSS grid as bad as true
super cool news modules in the CSS spec
which will allow you to build your own
version of this chat app just customize
exactly how you want it now you can say
goodbye to all of this beautiful code
and the next time you see it you'll
actually understand it as you will have
coded it yourself or at least together
with me and in the next screencast we'll
actually start doing that so stay tuned
and I'll see you there
hey and welcome to the first lecture we
will actually jump into the code and
start building so now I'm in the app KS
file and as you can see the app
component is significantly simpler than
it used to be I've removed all the logic
so all that were left with is the render
method which hare returns the four
children of the app component that
results in a significantly simpler UI
each of the components are simply
rendering out its respective name now
we're gonna start by building out this
message list component error and it can
be found down here so what we're gonna
do of course is render out a list of
messages down here so we need to remove
this help text and write some JSX but
first we need data and we're not gonna
hook up with the transit API just yet
so I'm gonna paste in some dummy data
basically an array contains three
objects and each of the objects contains
a sender ID property and the text
property and this is a simplified
version of the data we'll get from chats
get later on now in order to render this
stuff out on the page you have to first
escape out of the JSX syntax because we
can't just write JavaScript inside of
JSX we have to use curly brackets in
order to embed JavaScript expressions
inside of JSX so inside of here we can
do dummy data not math fetch out the
object itself which were calling message
and we also need the index using a fat
arrow function and for each of the items
we're going to return a gift right now
we're in JSX land again so we need to
move over to JavaScript plan
so we'll do curly brackets again and
let's just start by rendering out
message dot txt we run this as you see
we're rendering out the messages
brilliant so now I want to give you your
very first challenge I want you to
render out the sender ID and addition to
the text so pause the screencast right
now jump into the code and change it so
that it renders out the sender ID as
well and if you don't manage to do it
then just
zoom back to the screencast and I'll
show you how to do it okay so go ahead
and do that right now okay so I hope you
manage to solve this task let's see how
it's done
so I'm suspecting that some of you might
have been tempted to simply add rather
div tag here the message not sender I'd
be and if you try to do that you'd see
now we run the code we're getting an
error react is basically saying that
adjacent JSX elements must be wrapped in
an enclosing tag which means you can't
simply render out two JSX elements
besides each other like this you have to
wrap them in an closing tag and you
can't actually do it
if you use an array so that's a feature
react added in version 16 but we're
gonna use the in closing tag so what we
want to do is wrap both of these another
dim like that you run it it works
beautiful now I wanna add more classes
in order to apply some styling let's run
it again oh it looks beautiful however
we're getting another message in the
console it's saying that each child in
an array or a trader should have a
unique key prop so what we need to do is
give this item here key prop like this
and this is why I want to fetch out the
index as well because we can use the
index as the key if you run this again
it works and we're not getting the
warning now it's actually not
recommended to use the index as the key
rather recommended to use a unique ID
and using the index is kind of seen as a
last resort solution because the reason
we're doing this is so that react
properly can identify these dynamically
created children from each other so that
if you start adding removing replacing
and shuffling around of these items
react 100% how to separate the items
from each other based upon their ID but
since we're not gonna change the order
of our items right now we can use the
index for this dummy example however in
the next screencast we're
we going to fetch real data from the
traffic API and swap this index out with
a more stable solution so we're actually
progressing pretty quickly now so stay
tuned for the next lecture as it'll be
packed with interesting learnings
hey let's have a look at how I can get
started with the chatty API so traffic
is is built by pusher which you can find
on pusher comm they have a really nice
collection of several DPI's which help
you create collaboration and
communication features in your apps one
we're gonna use is called chant kit and
it's probably the easiest way to
implement chat in your app it's in
public beta and it's free while it's in
public beta and they'll always have a
generous free plan so you don't have to
worry about suddenly having to pay now
in order to get started you need to sign
in or create an account and then you'll
take into the dashboard we can see an
overview over the instances you have for
their various api's and if you click
this instance is here under chat kit
you'll see your instances the one we're
gonna use for this course is called
scramble chat kit course when you head
into that one you'll get to an overview
page where you have all the keys tokens
and stuff like that what you need in
order to connect with chat kit and you
can also create users and rooms here
manually for when you're playing around
with it and experimenting in the next
screencast we're going to connect our
app with my chatot instance and i'm also
going to challenge you to connect our
app to your chat kit instance as you
should have your own instance and i
shall have mine so i'm looking forward
to see you there
hey in this lecture we're finally going
to connect with the trap gate API so
that we can fetch out the messages from
a given room now the first thing we need
in order to do that as the chat kit sdk
as you can see under dependencies here
i've installed the sdk atomic using NPM
but I could easily also have simply
linked to the source from the HTML
because they have CDNs in which you can
just point a script tag to and then
easily fetch out the sdk that way as
well however we're gonna use NPM and the
way we get ahold of the SDK it's by
doing import that get from your target
then there's a question how do we hook
up a react component with an API and the
way you want to do that is through using
a lifecycle method called component mid
mount and it's triggered directly after
the render method has been invoked so
here we'll create a chat manager and
we'll use the chat kit dot chat manager
to create that and inside of here you
can specify a few parameters first we
need our instance locator to tell job
get which instance we want to connect
with and that is the one we created here
it's called scrim but rath get course
and here you can see that we're getting
an instance locator and I've copied this
one to the config dot J's file Harris
and I'm exporting this one along with
another one which we'll look at in a
minute so I'll simply do import I'll
just copy these from config like that
now I can do instance locator - locator
like that and actually as the key and
the variable which is holding the value
meaning the instance locator string it's
called the same I can actually omit this
one here and use do like this and we
also need to specify a user ID because
traffic it needs to know which user
we're connecting with this instance and
as you can see down here in the
dashboard I've created a user manually
here so we're gonna use that one user ID
or Morgan
finally there's the Tolkien provider
which will create using new chant kicked
token provider like that here we need to
pass in the URL not URL it's the one
we're getting if we scroll down to test
token provider here you see your test
token provider endpoint and this is only
for testing purposes what you'd rather
have in production here is an endpoint
which you have created for example using
note and there you would tend to get the
user what you could do using the trap
kits server SDK you also might want to
do some other stuff perhaps talk with
your own database and whether for
testing purposes we're just gonna use
this as token provider here in order to
authenticate ourselves so I've copied it
again in the config file and export it
as the token URL so I'm just gonna paste
in the token URL like this and now we
have a chat manager properly setup
meaning we can use it to do chat mandrin
dot connect that'll return a promise and
when that promise is resolved we get
access to the current user and the
current user object contains a bunch of
methods for interacting with the API so
the current user is our interface for
talking with the chat kit API we can
start off by doing current user doc
subscribe to rule like that in this
object we need to specify of course
which room we want to subscribe to using
the room I'd be and as you can see in
the interface here if we scroll a bit up
I created a room called random here and
I can interact with this room
programmatically using this identifier
here so I'll copy that one and paste it
in here then we need to provide it with
at least one hook we have a hooks
property here and the most important
hook which basically is an event
listener is called on new message or
adolescents for new messages and when
we're building a cat room we want to be
notified every time a new message has
been emitted in the chatroom
so here message producing a fat arrow
function and I'm just gonna console log
out the message dot txt
now let's run this code and as you can
see the console we're logging out three
messages hey how's it going great how
about you good to hear I'm great as well
and that is indeed the messages I've
already pre-created
in this room now if this room contained
tons of messages we could have
considered adding a message limit for
example ten messages that means the chat
kit would only fetch out the 10 latest
messages and you could set that to up to
a hundred
however by default it's 20 and I think
that's a suitable number which means we
can actually omit this so I'm gonna
remove it but I want you to be aware
that you can control that one thing you
might be a little bit confused over now
is that chat kit gave us the same data
as we had in our dummy data however now
we are actually indeed fetching it from
chat kit and in order for you to really
internalize this what I want you to do
now is actually to fetch messages from
your own instance and your own chat room
and these keys that you obtain here will
be the basis for the chat application
you'll create later on so I basically
want you to swap out the following
values your room ID the user ID also the
token URL and instance locator whoever
they're located in the config dot J's
file so a lot comments here and here
swap out this one and this one and the
way you do that is by first heading over
to producer comm slash chat kit neither
scroll down to the sign up area or click
the sign up button here and you can
actually click this slide to get to
pusher comm slash target once you've
created an account you're taken to the
dashboard and there you're gonna click
the Create button
now create your very own track kit
instance which you'll give a name and
once you've done that you're taken to
the overview over your instance and the
first key you're gonna copy is this
instance locator to click the copy icon
right here and then head to configure a
s and swap it out right here
then you want to scroll a bit down
through the pest spoken provider and
here you need to check this box in order
to enable the test talk and provider
endpoint and you won't actually see it
at all until you've checked this box so
do that and then hit the copy icon go
back to the code and swap it out here
then scroll a bit up again and reduce
your name here hit create and then head
over to app j/s paste in your username
here once you've created a user you'll
be able to create a room give it a name
and hit create and then this little
alert box will pop up with the room
identifier which you'll copy and paste
in right here and then finally I want
you to enter a message into this field
here and hit Send because that'll send
the message manually through your chat
room and it's important to understand
that you won't be able to do this on my
instance because only I have access to
my instance dashboard and if you are to
create a chat application you need your
own instance you can't continue using my
instance locator as it's through the
instance you create rooms and I reckon
you want your own rooms in your chat app
by the end of this and not share rooms
with mine so go ahead and do all this
now and when you run this code you
should see the message you have entered
in here appear in the console and then
note down these keys if you are fetching
as I'm going to use them later on as the
basis of your very own chat app so good
luck with this and I'll see you in the
next screencast
hey there now we've managed to fetch
data from the chat kit API and log out
so that's good
however what we wanna do is actually
take this data the messages store it in
our component and then pass it down to
the message list which is the component
that's going to render this data out so
please do something else than simply
logging it out and specifically we need
to add a state to this app component and
state is one of two main ways of
handling data and react the other one is
called props and you'll be introduced to
that in a minute and throughout these
introductions you might feel a bit
confused at times in terms of what the
difference is between state and props I
at least was in the beginning I found
that the only way to really internalize
this is to just see a lot of examples
and write code yourself so I think as we
move along it'll be clearer and clearer
for you when it's suitable to your state
and when it's suitable to use props or
in short state is private for a
component so our state which we're going
to create now will only be state for the
app component here and it's also
possible to change the state from the
component itself however props is not
private it's shared between components
and the component to have props can't
change them directly themselves has to
go through some kind of state changed
higher up in the hierarchy now this
probably sounds very theoretical so
let's actually just get started so
you'll see it in action first thing we
need to create is a constructor method
the constructor is the very first method
that is called in the lifecycle of react
components and it's actually a special
method of es6 classes and it allows you
to interact with the this keyword which
points to the instance of this class
however before we interact with this we
have to call super and what super does
is called the constructor function of
the class which this class has been
extended upon so that is the react dot
component class so when recalling super
we're calling the constructor function
in the reactive component class
and that sets stuff up for us so that we
can start interacting with the state so
we'll be this rock straight and set that
as an object what we're gonna do here is
we're going to store the messages in the
state and we'll initialize it as an
empty array what we now can do is for
every new message we get from chat kit
we'll do this
dot set state and inside of this object
we're describing how we want our new
state to look like so we want the
messages to change and what we wanna do
is actually add this latest message to
the end of the this top state dot
messages array so we use es6 and the
rest our state of ms address and then
add the latest message at the end of
this new array and you might be a little
confused what these three dots here are
that's called the spread operator and it
allows you to expand this dot state up
messages array to rather fit into the
array we're creating here so you look at
it as if we're taking the this dot state
of messages which is encapsulated in two
square brackets like here so if we
didn't have these three dots it would be
like this they would just take up one
item in this new array but now with the
three dots rather expanding it so that
they forget about their old square
brackets and just fit into this new
array instead so this array is expanded
to fill the brackets from this raid
definition rather than its old
definition and this here basically
creates a whole new array which contains
no reference to the previous objects
here as this is a new copy of this dot
state dot messages with the latest
message concatenated at the end and you
might now ask so why didn't we just do
like this list not state up messages
drop push message and
that's because this push method would
actually modify the original array so
we'd modify the state using dot push you
should never do that the only way you
should modify the state is through this
that set state meaning that we need to
copy this dot state dot messages and
expand it into our new array while
adding the latest message at the end so
now that we have messages in our state
and it's being updated as new messages
comes along let's try and render out
restarts data messages rerun the code
and there you can see that they start
state up messages is being filled up
with objects as they're added to the
state in this on new message look let's
remove this one here and this one here
now what we want to do is pass this data
down to message lists and we're going to
do that through props and the way you
give a component props is through giving
it what looks like an HTML attribute
let's do messages equals and then we
have to escape out of the gray sxe on
there we're going to add a JavaScript
array and it's of course this state
Gotham s address now we can head over to
the message list and let's try to swap
the dummy data out with this doc
Crocs dot mess so dress and run this
code and as you can see we're getting
the exact same data that we had and this
does not come from the dummy data
actually we can remove this one we can
render it again and now fetching real
data from the chart kit API and
displaying it in a wrap the way it
happens just to go through that quickly
is whenever chat kit registers a new
message in this chatroom this event
handler is triggered we're doing this
dot set state taking the previous list
of state messages and concatenating it
with the latest message so that this
array here is updated and then when we
render the message list component we
pass along the messages by giving it a
prop called messages giving it the value
of this toss state up messages
the way react works is that every time
this data here changes it'll trigger
re-render and the data will be passed
down to the message list that'll trigger
a rerender of message list and here
we're simply mapping through that data
this dot props dot messages remember now
it's props it's not state because the
state is private and can only live up in
the app component and when you pass it
down to components like this it is
turned into props so we did this stop
props up messages map through it and
just render it out as we did with the
dummy data so we're moving along really
faster we already have an app which
talks to the chat kit API that's pretty
cool now in the next lecture we're going
to turn this here into its own component
namely the message component
hey in this lecture we're going to
finish up the message component here
because as you remember when we broke
down our UI into components we wanted
each of the messages to be their own
component as well and here I have the
setup for that component however it just
contains an empty div so what it needs
to do is move some of the content from
here and into the message J's file or
actually let's start by importing the
message component into the message list
file like that now actually render it
out do a message like that so we're
gonna replace this here with this
component here and then fix up this
component so that the render is out
these stuff we want so the first thing
we need is to move this key here over to
the message and we also need to pass
down some data basically won't the
sender ID and the text and now I'm
actually gonna call the sender ID here
for you to name I think it makes more
sense to call a username message sender
ID because a message component in itself
should take a username prop and a text
prop and shouldn't care that here in the
underlying data that's powering the
message that it's called a sender ID I
think what semantically it makes sense
to call it a username where's the text
drop an easily be called
text which is what it's also called in
the data so this is a new stuff this is
the old stuff let's now copy these two
lives here and delete the whole thing
and then going to message not the ass
like that
now referring to message here and that's
Andrade that's wrong here we need to
refer to this table crops not username
and dress top problems not text so let's
run the code and as you can see it's the
works so now we've actually passed data
down to steps starting from the app
component where the data lived as state
passed it down to the message list
component as a messages prop in the
message list we got access to the
messages through this dot props tap
messages you loop through it and then we
pass some of that data namely the sender
ID and the text down to the message
component has two different prompts
username and text so in the message
component we're doing this dot prop
stock username and they start prop stop
text now this is really nice little
component it's very stupid the only
thing in knows is that it's supposed to
render out a username and some text when
it doesn't do anything else which is
great according to the principle of
single responsibility so what I want you
to do now actually is to turn this into
a so-called functional component because
when a component doesn't have state or
any lifecycle methods or any other
methods you can actually make it even
simpler than a class can turn it into a
function and given that functional
components have so many constraints
they're less prone to bugs and a lot of
people prefer them over class components
so go ahead and check out the
documentation right here this link where
functional components are described and
try to change this to a functional
component and once you've done it or
given up resume back to the screencast
then I'll show you how to do this well
so go ahead and do that right now okay
hopefully you manage the task let's now
see how we can turn this into a
functional component gonna remove the
class keyword and we're not going to
extend upon the reactive component class
we're just going to do crawl function
syntax and this is a function it can't
have eight and render method so we're
gonna remove the render method as well
and basically just return the JSF
directly and final thing we just need is
the props which is the argument of the
function and means that we don't refer
to this dot props dot username we have
to do props dot username and props that
text which actually know this inside of
this function this is undefined so let's
run this and boom it works so now you're
really starting to get a lot of tools in
your react.js tool belt and in the next
lecture you're going to learn about
event handlers so stay tuned and I'll
see you there
hey in this lecture we're going to build
out this send message form component
that is the one which you can see down
here that's where you can write your
messages as you can see we have the
basic set up here already it's just a
form with a class name and an input
field it has a placeholder and it's of
type text of course let's change this
placeholder to something like and like
that it's a bit more descriptive okay so
the thing with form elements is that
they kind of keep their own internal
state based upon the user inputs because
when I type something in here the
element needs to keep track of what I've
typed in however as you know from
learning about state and react we
usually want to keep the internal state
in well this dot state and if we rather
control the content of an element like
this in the components state we get a
single source of truth and our
application becomes less prone to bugs
so let's take whatever the user inputs
into this input field and shove it into
the state of the send message form
component what will then do is that
we'll use the on change event handler
this one basically says that whenever
this input field changes one that
whenever the value of a changes fire off
whatever function we specify inside of
these curly brackets let's do this drop
and rule change in here so this one is
listening for changes in the input field
and it's invoking this method whenever a
change is fired
however handle change hasn't been
defined yet so we'll need to define it
like this here we get access to the
event and let's just log out we adopt
target and off well you like that run
the code
as you see it's now logging out whatever
we type into the input field so now we
only need to take this value here and
add it to the component state and as you
hopefully remember we need to create a
constructor method in order to
initialize the state like that and we
need to call super
then we can do this not state equals an
object and it'll have one key called
message like that and we'll initialize
it as an empty string to begin with now
let's see if we can update the state in
this handle change method they stopped
set State message and we'll set that to
the edocs target profit value we run the
code try to input something we're
getting an error cannot set properly set
state of undefined and that is because
the this keyword is undefined inside of
this method it's not bound to the
component instance which is up here in
the constructor and that ties back to
how JavaScript itself works and the way
to solve this is through in the
constructor do this dot handle change
equals this nots handle change and then
bind this which we do have access to in
the constructor to the Vista panel
change method so now if we run the code
try to input stuff hello
we're not getting an error we can
actually instead of console logging out
not one here let's rather do list out
state not message down here run the code
and write that yo and we can see that we
now in the render method have access to
the state so what we'll do now might
seem a bit weird but we'll actually set
the value of the input field to this
start state not message now all this
thus is that we are controlling the
value in the input field
programmatically so that it can only be
whatever we have in the state at any
given time so if we run it now it works
well however what's happening here is
that when the unchanged event listener
is triggered we invoke the handle change
method it updates the state and then
react triggers a rerender in which the
value which is passed in to the input
field here has been changed and thus
it's updated in the UI so it's going
through the state with
for your keystroke turns into a change
in the user interface like that so now
we have what's called a controlled
component we're controlling how it works
and we don't have any duplicate state
and where the input field keeps track of
its State and the component keeps track
of its state and we don't have to hope
for the two states to match we know that
they are all always match so the next
thing we need to do is hook an on submit
a vent listener onto the form so that
when they hit enter we'll take the
message and send it off or will at least
in this lecture prepare the sending off
and then the next lecture we'll see how
we can send it off to chat get the way
we'll do this is very similar to what we
did previously on submit as that's the
event listener for forms and this drop
handle submit then submit create that
one here here we first want to prevent
the fault and then we wanna send message
somehow and we of course need to bind
this method to this as well like that so
did we in this handle submit event
handler get access to this that state
drop message
cuz that's the message we're gonna send
off so let's remove this one run the
cold submit and there we log route from
this place right here
now finally I wanna point out that the
on submit and on change our event
listeners provided by react and they are
wrappers on top of the native event
listeners which we write without the
capital C and s hover miss drop hang
trained and this up handle submit could
have been called whatever we want could
have done for example handle form and
form run the cold oops
then I also have to fix this one like
that run the cold and submit and it
works
these names are created by me wears on
submit and on change needs to be called
exactly that let's go back to handle
submit I like to have the event
listeners and event handlers resemble
each other though only with swapping out
on with handle as I think that's a good
practice which makes the code readable
and understandable so in the next
lecture we're going to learn how to take
our messages send them off through the
chat kit servers so that the message
it's broadcasted to everybody who is a
part of this chat room so I'm looking
forward to see you there
hey let's now learn how we can take our
messages and send them off to track it
we have set up the send message forum so
that we're ready to do that down here we
got to change the fjs a little bit as
well because as you might remember the
interaction with the chat kit API
happens through this current user object
and that's one which we got access to in
the component in mount method as we
practice to it after we get connected
with the chat manager whoever it's only
available inside of this scope right
here and that's not good we want it to
be available to the entire component
instance because we're gonna do current
user dot a send message in order to send
messages so in order to do that we have
to do a couple of things first we gotta
do this dot current user equals to
current user so we're taking the current
user and simply hooking it on to the
component itself and by doing that we
can for example create a new method send
message will simply do this turn user
dot send message like that that's of
course only possible since we did this
here and actually for the sake of
consistency let's also do this drop the
current user about subscribe to room
here however you probably know what we
need to do in order to enable the send
message method do you have access to the
this keyword we of course have to bind
it so now we have access to this inside
of send message that enables us to get
the current user object and call the
send message method and inside of that
we're gonna specify two things that is
the text we want to send like this and
we'll get that as an argument of the
send message function and we're also
going to specify the room ID and for now
I'm just gonna hard code back in and as
you probably remember es6 allows us to
omit this one here when the key and the
variable that holds the value are
identical so you can do it like this and
now comes a concept which I struggled to
understanding and I know that a lot of
people find it hard to wrap their heads
around because as you've experienced
here
when we've sent the messages down as a
prop to message list data flows in one
direction in reacted from parent that's
the apt is true child sure these here
whoever now are in a position where we
somehow need to get the data from down
in the message form that being the data
were storing in the state here and we
need to send that up through the app dot
j s component because that's the one
that'll send this data off to chat kids
so this is called the inverse data flow
in react and there's a couple of ways of
looking at this conceptually either that
we're sending a method down or that were
reaching up from child to parent in
order to trigger a method so what we'll
do is we'll take this send message and
send it down search as a prop it's not
send message like that now
send message form will get access to
this method it again has access to this
dot current user dot send message in the
send method form down here we'll do this
drop box drop send message passing in
this dot straight drop message remember
restoring the message in the state so
you can either look at it as if we're
down here in the send method form or
kind of reaching our hand up to this
method here or you can look at it on a
conceptual level that app dot Reyes is
passing down this method so that send
message form can borrow it but either
way the data kind of flows the wrong way
from child to parent so that's why they
call it inverse dataflow okay let's try
it out the game denied entered Luke's
room ID what's of type oops
spelling mistake I written rude ID room
ID let's try it again run the code again
and hit enter
boom that worked we now sent the
off to chat get via they start current
user not send message and then since we
are listening for new messages here and
setting the state adding the latest
message through the state here that
state got updated which again triggered
re-render so that this message list also
got re-rendered and if results in for
messages being displayed in the chat
instead of just the three final thing I
want to do in the send message form is
that once we have sent it we want to
clean up the input field so do they stop
sets eight message and turn that into an
empty string again now if we run it so I
grab the input field is automatically
blanked out after the message has been
sent so we're starting to get a really
cool town application here the next step
now is to start creating the room lists
and also enable you to create new rooms
so I'll see you in the next lecture
heyyyyyy in this lecture we're gonna
fetch out all the rooms in our chat kit
instance and then display them in this
room list component here which you can
see the skeleton for right here so as
you know all communication with the API
happens in the app component our only
smart component and it happens through
the this dot current user object so what
we'll do is this drop current user dots
get growing the book rooms like that
that returns a promise and when that
promise has been resolved we get access
to the renewable rooms like that what we
then want to do is and these trainable
rooms to the state is that set the state
Greenville rooms like that ever
drainable rooms aren't the only rooms in
this chat kit instance they're just the
rooms that we haven't joined yet that
this user here hasn't joined yet though
in our instance there might be other
rooms as well namely rooms that this
user has joined and they are available
in this that current user dot rooms so
let's add them to the state as well call
it joined rooms and we'll find them in
this wrap current user drop rooms and
now that we're saying these in state you
also have to initialize them
Bruce joined Bruce like that now I also
want to add a couple of statements here
that and down here I'm connecting you
now have multiple promises in this
method and if any of them fail we want
to get a hint of what's going on and
this component in mount starting to get
pretty massive so we're going to
refactor it a little bit later on if you
find it to be a bit confusing a bit bit
too massive don't worry we'll clean it
up afterwards
for now though but see if we're able to
send these rooms down to the room list
component
so what we'll do is we'll give the room
list component a prop called Bruce in it
use the spread operator to combine the
two arrays of this dot state route
drainable rooms with this that state god
join groups back now in the room list we
can log out this stop drops not boots
run the code and see that we read
logging out after a few renders an array
filled with objects which probably is
our roofs so now we need to render the
rooms right here and to do that we're
gonna do the exact same thing we did
with the messages they start props nuts
rooms brought not get access to the room
in the callback function where we're
going to return list item just wrapping
around an anchor tag it goes to nowhere
but with contains room dot name and as
we're using list items here we need to
add an unordered list just wrapping
these and I also want to have an h3
which says your rooms we also need to
give this list item a key as you know
this room dot ID and for styling
purposes we'll give it a class name of
room like that so let's try to run the
code beautiful we're now rendering out a
list of all the rooms we have in our
trafficking instance this is both the
ones I've joined and once I can join and
it looks really nice actually
so in the next lecture we look at how to
join a specific room display the
messages from that room and also send
messages to that room so you can jump in
between rooms and chat as much as you'd
like
so actually starting to approach a fully
functional chat app
heyyyyyy in this lecture we're going to
learn how to subscribe to specific rooms
so that we can click on them and start
chatting in them and to do that we need
to work a little bit with all the old
we've added to component did mount
because now we're just automatically
subscribing to this specific room when
the component mounts that's why we get
these messages here by default but what
we want to do is that when you enter
into the app you shouldn't automatically
subscribe to your room you should make a
conscious choice of a clicking on the
room you want to subscribe to so the
first thing we need to do is remove this
subscribe to room method this piece of
code here and create a subscribe to room
method place that in there now let's
just call this from here to see that it
works and of course as always we need to
remember to bind this mat like that
let's run the code as you can see we're
automatically subscribing to that room
so our method works now what I also want
to do is pull out this one here turn
that into its own method as well all it
gets rooms and then also replace this
code with this stuff get rules that and
of course find it now we have a much
more manageable component in mount
method and what we want to do is enable
the user to click a room and thus
subscribe to it so we need to pass down
the subscribe to room method down to the
room list through the subscribe to room
equals they start subscribe to rule
let's make this a bit more readable like
that and inside the room list when you
click on this anchor tag here on quick
this stopped crops not subscribe to room
and then passing rule dot ID so here
we're using an anonymous function to
wrap this function call here because if
we were to do like this this here would
be called immediately when this
component renders then we only want to
call it on the click event so on the
quick event this anonymous function gets
invoked which again invokes this one and
we actually don't need those two curly
brackets there so let's also it's
readable I like to add them to multiple
lines if I have more than one attribute
or prop on these JSX elements like that
now this is that prop starts subscribe
to rule will call subscribes room up
here then we also need to pass in the
room ID as we pass that along and just
replace this one with the room ID and
now we should be able to subscribe to
rooms through clicking on these items
here meaning will actually remove this
first subscribe to room from the
component in math we now will enable the
user to do that instead of doing it
automatically so we'll run the code and
click on NFL and as you can see we got
messages from that chatroom beautiful
now if we head into welcome as well
we'll see that we have a buggy
so the welcome messages was placed after
the NFL messages and that's not good
that's because when we subscribe to room
and we get our own new message event
listener we're simply just continuing to
append new messages to the state so what
we need to do before we subscribe to
room is clean up a slate set the
messages to an empty array again now
we've run it in the NFL oops
this thought state of messages is not a
function of course I have to do they
stop set the state like that
Oh welcome yes
now it works what we now need to do is
to make sure that we keep the joinable
rooms and join rooms properly updated
because the list you can see here
contains both the rooms you have joined
and the rooms you can join and they look
for this app completely a similar
regardless of whether or not you have
joined it and the thing is when you
subscribe to room
that means when you're listening for
messages and displaying them here you're
automatically joining it as well so if
there's a room that I haven't joined yet
let's say for example this NB a room and
I joined that then these two joinable
rooms and drawing rooms should change
one room from the joinable rules should
be extracted and put into the joined
rooms array so after i've subscribed to
a room we actually need to call this get
trainable rooms again and update the
state in case one of the rooms are do a
switch array so here this subscribe to
room returns a promise then then we get
access to the room and there will simply
do this dropped get rules like that so
valley cap here like that now we should
be keeping track of the rooms correctly
we then need to do is to make sure that
we can send messages to the correct room
cuz right now when we're triggering the
send message just hard coding in that
we're sending a message to this specific
room and that of course doesn't work and
the answer to that is also to be found
in this callback function here because
what we then can do do this that set
state and we can keep track of which
room we're currently at by doing room ID
and setting it could be room drop I mean
now I need to add this to the state one
rule in initializing it as well
room ID let's just initialize it as null
and when we send the message
just this stout state done groom ID
let's try this
oh I haven't joined any rooms yet
because we haven't called subscribe to
room
if I click NFL for example reference
error error isn't defined let's see I
had three hours here rerun again I click
FL is not defined yet again oops I did a
weird mistake care I didn't wrap this in
a console log now let's write NFL and
I'm getting the messages yes and yes I'm
able to chat in that room as well let's
try the Premier League one totally works
brilliant so now I can change jump
around to any room I want and chat with
the people in the room championship
random NBA general so this is really
cool however there are two more things
we need to fix in order to make our room
list component complete namely making
sure that these rooms are always
displayed in the order we want them to
be displayed in and that we're
highlighting which room you're currently
at so in the next screencast we'll fix
both those things
hey in this lecture we're going to fix a
couple things
in our room list component and the first
one being that if I now paste in a new
username here which hasn't joined any
rooms yet however it has been created on
this instance in the chat kit web
interface so it is a part of this
instance though it hasn't joined any
rooms what'll happen is that when I run
the code and I try to join any rooms you
can see that the rooms seem to shuffle
around and that's not a good user
experience and it's because rooms jump
from being joinable rooms to being
joined rooms and namely happens in this
that set state here when we have fetched
out the joinable rooms after the user
has joined the room and this start
current user dark rooms is by the way
updated automatically but the point
being that an object has jumped from
here to here and thus the order of this
top prop start rooms down in room list
which we are mapping through here has
changed so the order in the user
interface will change and the way to
solve this is to create an ordered array
up here called ordered rules equals this
props not rules and we'll use a spread
operator since we're now going to sort
this array and we're going to us at a
compare function that takes two
arguments and here we're allowed to tell
this algorithm how we wanted to sort our
new array we're gonna sort it by ID the
way it works is that if this returns a
negative number then a will be seen as
less than B according to our sort
function or if we return a positive
number then a will be seen upon as
greater than B and it'll sort it
accordingly
so now it should sort our rooms in
ascending order based upon their IDs and
we need to create a new array as sort
would indeed modify the original array
and you should never modify props so
then we'll take the order rooms and swap
this out here we'll run the code now
let's try joining
who seems to be working really good they
don't jump around COO so now you only
have one more thing left and that is to
highlight which room you're currently at
because right now we don't really know
which room rat
let's click welcome and what we want to
happen is for this item here to glow up
a little or to change color the way we
do that is we're going to give this list
item class of active if this item which
is rendered also is the same as the room
ID meaning that it's the one we're
chatting in at that point of time what
we'll do
this way to cast down room ID from this
top state hmm ID then we'll go back to
room list and here constant active and
if this rod drops Rock room ID equals to
ID then we're going to return otherwise
return an empty string and now goo here
just very easily and paths make those
two strings together so if it's looping
through the current active room then
it'll give an active class to this list
item here let's run the code we hit the
Welcome room
ambu it's now white as we have styled it
in the CSS so that the list item should
be white if it has to class some active
so that was it I hope you learned
something and I'll see you in the next
lecture
hey in this lecture I'm gonna show you a
trick for automatically scrolling down
to the bottom when new messages appear
like for example this right my name is
pear hitting Enter
nothing apparently happened whoever if I
scroll down ooh
there was the message and I sent it as
Jane Smith
so rather MA no my name is Jane turn it
again didn't seem to appear
it actually has appeared so we need to
automatically jump down let's go in here
actually move this back to Morgan that's
me and the way we solve this is through
running the component did update method
now this is yet another of the lifecycle
methods in react and it's called
directly after a component has been
updated so this is nice time for
scrolling down if you want to do that
and first we need to grab hold of the
message list component itself the Dom
node basically salute crumbs node and
we'll use method of the react Dom
library Dom and we need to import backs
yeah Dom from react like that you find
Dom node as in this and preventing undo
it's at the node dot scroll top equal to
nodes
dropped scroll height the scroll drop is
how far we've scrolled down and the
scroll height is how long our entire
scrollable element is so when we're
sending the scroll top to equal the
scroll height
we're actually scrolling as far down as
possible as we can and the scroll height
is actually measured from the top so it
can't actually be as far from the top as
the entire height but that doesn't
matter this will basically scroll the
window all the way to the bottom so
let's run the code join the room now we
are scroll to the bottom if we try right
my name is air we're scroll down however
there are certain situations where we
don't want this action to trigger
for example let's say I'm reading
through all the messages up here and
then suddenly the new message appears at
the bottom now what I'm gonna do now I'm
actually gonna head into another window
which you can't see here it's grimbo and
then I'm gonna write a message from that
client so I've connected from that
client as well so just sit tight I'm
gonna write another message and send it
and boom suddenly this was sent from
another client another browser basically
which I couldn't show you via scrim bar
but it was a little bit annoying that
when I was reading messages up here
suddenly I got pulled down to the bottom
so what we want to do is check if I'm
also somewhere near the bottom and in
such case we'll jump down before I'm far
up here just keep appending messages
down below and I'll actually have to
scroll down to see them and perfect
place for doing this is component will
update and that is triggered right
before the component has been updated
and here we can check where I am in the
scroll position so first we need to grab
hold of the node here as well and we'll
do this should scroll bottom and if our
node scroll top that's how far we have
scrolled down and our no dropped clients
height that's the height of our window
here so now if we scroll down 20 pixels
or something now our scroll top is 20
and our clients height is this entire
window and it's maybe 350 pixels so
let's say that this in total is 370
pixels if that is greater than or equal
to the node dock scroll height this the
entire element meaning that we are
actually at the bottom since how far we
have scrolled down plus the height of
this window here equals the entire box
or more than or equal that's just in
case we by some reason managed to scroll
further down
then we should scroll to bottom so we'll
do here if
this that scroll to bottom then we're
gonna do this out let's run the code
I'll bring the welcome ring hey boom
we're scroll down but if we now scroll
bit up and we write yo ah actually
worked we didn't auto scroll and finally
I want to give a little buffer so in
case we're down here or almost at the
bottom we still want it to jump down so
I'll do that by adding plus a hundred
here now therefore almost at the bottom
it works as well really nice so now
we're starting to get a chat application
which actually has a good user
experience so then the final feature is
to make this new room form work and
after we've done that we're done with
all the JavaScript and I'm gonna show
you how to modify this chatroom so that
you can create your very own chatroom
both in terms of layout and theme so you
basically can start chatting with your
friends with your homemade chat
application so it seems I'll be holding
my promise I gave you in the beginning
that you will end up with your very own
custom personal chat application at the
end of this course so I'm looking
forward to see you in the next
screencast I'll see you there
heyyyyyy in this lecture we're going to
build out the new room form component
which basically allows you to type in
the name for a room and then it'll pop
up here and you can start chatting in
that room and people who are part of
this trad kit instance can also join
that room and chat with you and they can
of course also create groups so this
will be very similar to how we did the
send message form so I'm gonna go
quickly through how we'll build out the
new room form as you remember we prefer
to create controlled components
so we're gonna give this one an on
change handler and then trigger this top
handle change which is a method will
right here in it will do this top set
state and set the room name to drop
target drop value now we cannot work
with state without doing super in the
constructor like acts super and also
initialize the state to room name equal
an empty string next up we need an on
submix went listener on the form will do
this top handle submit and they're
simply first prevent default then we'll
tell the app component that we want to
create a new room and way to do that as
you remember is to pass down a method
from the app component down to the child
component to create room like that not
write any code here yet let's just pass
this down create room so we have the
architecture and also we need to
remember to bind this that and that now
in this the room form will do this drop
start create room nothing in the name
which we have in this the state dot room
name so now let's
in the app component mmm name a logging
of the rule name just to see who can
make it work
I think oops
cannot read properly it's at stake upon
the find what am i done it has to be
down in the new room form they start of
course I forgot to bind this in our two
event handlers that's how it is the code
sometimes a lot of things to remember
and will copy this and handle submit
like that will run again and my new room
like that hit enter and boom rule name
my new room so we are able to connect to
the two components and pass down the
method for creating new rooms so now the
final thing to do is to just create a
new room do that through yet again use
this dot current user and it has a
method called create roof in it pass in
the name of the room name but we
actually can do now we can rather call
this for name and omit this one here and
it returns a promise and when that
promise results we get access to the
room and what we're gonna do here is
subscribe to that room because I think
that's a good user experience when you
create a room we instantly jump into it
luckily as we have extracted the
subscribe to room functionality in a
method of itself we'll just do this that
subscribe to room passing in the room
drop IB and let's also add a capture if
we get an error
we're going to console log out earth
with create room log out the error now
let's run the code and let's say that
I'm a huge fan of the World Cup let's
like math and there we have a whole new
room called World Cup who'll win I'll
ask and I can cut in that room and now
I'm actually going to go to another tab
you won't be able to see that but I'll
login as another user in this chatroom
and then I'll send the message Brazil
that's what I said and that popped up
here immediately
so this chat works whoever finally we
need to empty this input field once we
have submitted it and we know of course
how to do that it's super simple
they stop start set state name like that
all right
champions we enter and it didn't get ooh
so I noticed that I in my rush had made
a mistake so I've actually forgotten to
set the value here explicitly meaning
but I haven't done like this rest on
state rock name
this wasn't a fully controlled component
as we only sent the state from this
input field to the component state who
didn't go full circle and set the value
based upon the state as well so that was
an error on my side and it can serve you
as an example of when you're trying to
do something quickly when you think you
know easily how it's done because you've
done it before because I had done it in
the send message form before then I was
in such a hurry that I forgot this and
there's a lot of things to remember when
you're coding and it's not a good idea
to blink that you have everything under
control
you've got to pay attention to the
details and double check so that you can
find those small little things you
forgotten to do which opens up the app
for bugs so let's try it out will write
growth for example submit it and boom as
you can see there it is while the new
room form has been cleared out now
finally I want to change this to create
like that so now we're almost finished
with all the JavaScript for this course
just think there's one last thing we
should do that is before you have joined
the room
it should say join the room here and if
we try to input some
thing and try to send a message to the
chocolate API we'll get an error because
we haven't defined which room we're
sending that message to so to fix this
we'll first head over to the message
list here in the render method want to
check if we actually have chosen the
room so then we need to pass down the
room ID like this and if this table
drops that room ID here I'm taking if
this top stock room ID is a full C value
so not a cruisee value then render this
stuff out here or return this stuff here
return and this is just the wrapper and
I've created another div which I say
left arrow and the text join a room in
it and then there's close this off so
like that let's try and run it nice yeah
this is drawing the room your own room
it is pairs and then in order to disable
the input field before we have joined
the room I'm going to have to a down to
send message form and the way we
disabled an input field is by giving it
an attribute called disabled and if it's
true it'll be disabled so what we'll
send down here from app is actually a
prop called disabled and we'll give it
the opposite value of this that state
not room ID because if the room ID is
null then this will evaluate to true
meaning this disabled will be true and
this not drops the Seybold will be true
so let's try this now test go in the
room and I can't enter anything into the
symbol field if I join championship for
example I can brilliant so that was
actually the last piece of JavaScript we
needed to add to our app in the next
lecture we're going to start modifying
the chat room using CSS variables and
CSS grid so that you can create your
very
own personalized chat application which
is just the way you like it
hey as we now have built out all the
features of our chat app it's time for
you to get your own copy of the code so
that in the next couple of screencasts
when i'll show you how to customize the
layout of the app you'll be able to do
that on your very own copy and not using
my code and i'm gonna explain you this
through using slides so the first thing
you want to do is click the Settings
icon here at the top of the left side
bar that'll open up this menu and click
on the clone workspace that'll open up a
modal I want you to select playground
and then give it a title and hit the
confirm button and then you'll be taken
to your very own scrim but playground
and you might have to sign in if you
haven't done already as this will be
saved to your profile you'll see your
avatar here in the top right corner and
you can also find this playground from
your own profile and then the next step
is to connect this playground through
your own Chad kit instance and if you
followed along in screencast number 6
where you obtained your own instance
locator key test token provider and user
name you can just paste those in to the
project right now however if you didn't
do that I'm gonna revisit how to do
exactly that
so first head over to chat kit you can
click this slide to get to the page sign
up and then you're taking to the trap
kit dashboard here you want to click the
Create button which then opens up this
modal where you'll give your instance a
name hit the create button and then
you're taken to the overview over your
child kit instance and when you create
an app you always want your own instance
you don't wanna share instances with
anybody else as it's in the instances
that you create rooms you want full
control over your own rooms
so copy this instance located here you
can click the copy icon and then paste
it into the second line in the configure
is so swap it out here and then you
scroll a bit down will you see test
token provider there you must check this
enabled box in order to see your test
token provider endpoint so this box will
be unchecked and you need to check it
and then
this icon to copy your test token
provider in point and then paste it in
right here we've done that scroll a bit
up to the instance inspector and then
create your own user hit create and also
create a room and hit the create button
you'll see this room input field once
you create a user as you need to create
a user first in order to create a room
then paste your user name right in here
and with those few easy steps you have
the setup you need in order to customize
your very own Chara
vs CSS grid and CSS variables throughout
the next two lectures so I'll see you
there
hey in this lecture I'm gonna teach you
about CSS grid and how we're using CSS
grid to layout the different components
and how you very easily can swap around
on these and turn this chat application
into exactly the type of application you
want layout wise so here is our code for
creating the grid first to display grid
we're setting the height to a hundred
percent and we're then defining some
columns and some rolls and then template
areas Before we jump into exactly what
these mean let's see what it does
actually because then happens is that
CSS splits the entire div which is the
app live here
traps our entire application it splits
it into columns and rows and basically
turns it into a grid and as you can see
we have six columns and six rows and
reason we have that is because here
we've said in grid template columns that
we want to repeat 6 times 1 fraction
unit and fraction unit basically means
that we want each of the columns to be
equally wide I'm explaining fraction
units more in detail in my CSS grid
Coursera's grimbo module so you can
check out but for now just look at this
as it's giving each of the columns one
unit each unless though one of the
columns require more space which this
one here does because the content of it
forces it to be lighter than the sixth
of the width so then it captures a
little bit more space and the remaining
columns take up one fraction unit each
and now there's only five fraction units
left so they take up 1/5 of the
remaining space and I'm doing almost the
same with rows though here I'm not using
the repeat function where I'm saying 6
times one fraction unit I'm doing it
manually I'm saying 1 2 3 4 5 fraction
units then the last row should be 60
pixels tall twice that well that's
because I want this input row here to be
60 pixels tall regardless of the height
of the chat app itself because if
it was only 1/6 of the width then when I
did like this wouldn't be enough room to
enter text be tiny so I want to have a
fixed height so we've defined that 1/6
columns and 6 rows then we end up with
this huge grid here and what we then can
do is use grid template areas what we're
doing here is we're creating 6 strings
each representing a row and each
character separated by a space in these
strings represent a cell so when you see
them like this these cells here
represent a column so this is basically
a visual representation of this grid
here and now comes the interesting part
the characters here are representations
of the components because we have given
for example the new room form component
a grid area property of n meaning that
it will fill up the area in this visual
representation meaning it'll take the
spot down in the lower left corner and
indeed that is where our new room form
is located and of course this new room
form if we head into new room form Jas
it is the class name we have given it
and room list is the R and we have said
that we want it to occupy everything
above the new room form which as you can
see in the example is exactly why this
doing and here is the message list
component and here is the form component
itself I just call that an F I probably
call that an S since that starts an S to
be consistent but anyway we can actually
change that right now and rather do s
like that
so now here's the brilliant thing let's
say that I want the send message form
component to take up this space here as
well then I'll just paste it in and boom
as you could see now the send message
form became much taller doesn't look
very well though so I'll revert it what
is cool as for example but say we
perhaps want this entire column here to
be on the right hand side instead
take this here I'm gonna cut it out and
move over here and paste it in now
suddenly we have a UI which yeah works
perhaps I want to have the new room form
top instead of at the bottom then I'll
just do like this instead and how I can
create rooms up here and there's my
rooms and here's the chatting area so as
you can see it's really easy to
basically play around and create the
layout you want so now I want you in
your fork which you've already created
from the instructions of the previous
cost create your own layout which is not
like this one or try to experiment with
the layout and find one you like just
shuffle around on the items until you're
pleased with your layout and then in the
next lecture we're going to change the
theme as well meaning the colors of the
application so I'll see you there
heyyyyyy in this lecture we're going to
have a look at CSS variables which I'm
using to set the colors for the chatroom
and if you haven't seen CSS variables
before they worked like this so first
you need to define the scope of your
variables here we're selecting the route
tag which selects the root element and
in our case that is the HTML element
itself so that means that these apply
for our entire application
the syntax for them s - - variable name
and then variable value now what you
think can do is use this main color
inside of the root element in the Dom so
let's scroll a bit down and here you can
see that I'm using for the rooms list
the main color as the background color
and the syntax is var than the
parentheses and then the variables name
and you have to use the VAR you have to
use two dashes and as you can see in the
app I'm using this color not only as the
background here in the room list but
also on the background and the messages
themselves so it's so cool is that I now
can change this to for example red and
boom it changed in both places and just
have a look at my variable names here we
have main color secondary color main
text color secondary text color send
message form so this is actually super
powerful because now you can change the
entire theme for the app just by
changing these values here as most of
these are used multiple places
throughout the app so what I'm gonna do
now actually is paste in another color
let I found on line like that now I'm
just overriding this one
let's probably be explicit about that
and anyway now how my app is really
really nice and pink let's just through
adding these five variables and since
they are used all over the place here
and here and here and here it completely
changes the feeling of the app so what I
want you to do now is go online and find
color palette you like try and swap out
these here so that you get a chat app
which really matches you as a person
however don't do it in this I think you
should do it in the fork where you've
also perhaps change around on the layout
a little bit what you then will end up
with is something truly unique for
example let's say that you also run this
what you have here is a table which is
really different than the one we've been
coding on throughout this course at
least it looks really different even
though the underlying architecture is
similar let's go ahead and do that and
I'll see you in the final lecture of
this course or I'm going to talk about
how you can even further expand upon
your chat app
so you have finished the course to give
yourself a pat on the back because most
people who start online courses never
finish them so this is a really good job
of you you've taken time to invest in
your skills in a way that most certainly
is going to pay off and now you can jump
on to other challenges or if you want to
you can also further expand upon your
chat app and here I have a couple of
closing challenges or stretch goals or
call them whatever you want
it's voluntarily something you should do
if you want to continue diving into how
to create awesome trad applications
because what would really enhance the
user experience of this app is if you
added an online users component meaning
displaying which users are online in the
room at any given time and also typing
indicators to see if someone else are
typing in that room and I'm going to
point you towards how to solve these
they'll not give you the entire solution
for the online users you'll find the
information you need in the list dot
current user so let's log out this stop
turn user dot rules let's pick a room
for example the one at index 3 then do
user IDs you run this as you can see
that logged out a long list of user
names James back James White Jane Doe
Jane red as you can understand I'm not
that creative and coming up with new
names
however you could take this and display
it for example creating a component
above the chat room here or maybe you
want to merge it together with this
stuff here and somehow show user avatars
below the room if you want to do that
there's a really nice service called UI
I've Attar's
it allows you to generate avatars from
initials and then there's the typing
indicators and you can check out the
docs on room subscription hooks just
click this image and you'll be navigated
to it in another tab and the ones that
are relevant here are the on user
started typing and on user stopped
typing and they are to be added as hooks
here
so you'll do on YouTube started typing
then you'll get access to the user and
here you can render out users and as you
know should probably create a new
component for this but I'll stop giving
hints here because now it's your turn so
if you want to try to solve these
challenges and no matter what you do I
wish you good luck with your further
coding thank you